[Music]
what about the disciplines on campus
that seem to be primarily devoted to the
activist cause like because my view is
or my theory is that we've subsidized
the activist disciplines let's say
women's studies as a good example but we
could say Social Work and the faculties
of Education now as well I think they're
in the same in the same bin let's let's
let's put it that way the Women's
Studies programs in particular they're
their express goal expressed on their
websites is to produce social justice
radical left-leaning activists and so
like for a while one of the things I
proposed in Canada was that the
Conservatives in particular cut the
university funding by twenty five
percent so that the universities would
have to sort themselves out but then
that was that was a provocative claim
obviously but then I thought well that's
not a good idea because it opens up the
door to political interference in the
Academy and that's bad that's that's
right but the Academy has done a very
bad job of policing itself
methodologically and we have these
disciplines Women's Studies I think is a
prime example and that's being very much
criticized in Canada by Janice via Minko
who used to be yeah yeah she is and
she's she she's not in a natural milieu
when she's doing such things you know
she's a brave and tough person and she's
gone after the women's studies types on
methodological grounds particularly but
but there are people who are working
full-time at doing nothing but producing
the kind of poll so what do you have any
thoughts about yes I do I think so
here I teach in the business school here
and I teach a course called Professional
Responsibility and I teach my students
about their fiduciary duties their
duties to their employers the duties
that we have to each other and fiduciary
duty refers to a very very high standard
of care if you're managing someone's
money you know you you really have to be
committed to doing what's in their
interest not in your interest and I
think we need that concept in the
Academy we have a much prefer to be
called fiduciary duties or just
professional duties but I think we have
two primary professional duties that we
must never never betray
one the most important one in our role
as scholars is our duty to the truth we
must never say things that we think are
false or allow people to say things that
we think are false because we're afraid
if we challenge them we'll get in
trouble so we have a fiduciary due to
the truth and political ideological
commitments clearly warp us they make us
do things they make they push us so
we've got a whole we've got to recognize
that if we let our systems get out of
whack we are betraying the truth we're
systemically what you wanted we have a
systemic truth isn't problematic
betraying the truth and many of our
disciplines so I think we need an
awareness of that and we need to hold
herself to a higher standard
then in our role as teachers we have and
here we really can call it a fiduciary
duty these are people's children who are
sent to us to educate to enlarge their
minds to teach them skills if we were to
use them for our sexual pleasure it's
obviously a horrific crime but what is
it if we use them for our ideological
purposes if we say you've given your
children to educate I'm waging a
political battle I'm gonna try to get
use this as tools as tools that is
horrific that is unacceptable
we are violating our duties so I think
right but the response to that
especially from the postmodernist types
is that that's all there is
there's only ideological effect so back
to original question are there problem
departments absolutely so I wanted to
put forth these two commitments to truth
and to educating not indoctrinating yeah
and universities that embrace these
highest goals like the University of
Chicago I think is the best candidate
will probably find that they need to do
something about departments they don't
live up to those goals other
universities and I think Brown is
leading the way on this one so far I
mean that early 2015 the president had
all kinds of statements about Brown is
committed to social justice a
fundamental of bedrock commitment of
social justice she said so if some
universities choose to devote themselves
to social justice that's fine just be
upfront about it say so so students will
know if you want social justice training
you go to brown
but if you want to actually be trained
to find the truth to do research you go
to Chicago and I think we're gonna see
people flooding to Chicago and schools
like it so what I'm hoping what I'm
hoping so so that's the mechanism there
if they if they make that if they make
their statements public that the choice
of the students will be to go to the
universities that hold the principles
that you just described over the other
one so it'll be a marketplace choice
exactly that's right so that's what I
said when I talked about the Emperor's
New Clothes we have a situation we have
a gigantic market failure in which our
top universities are offering the
product that most consumers don't want
and so my prediction is that Chicago is
going to see a huge surge of
applications this year and if that's
true
I think other universities are going
they're gonna take notice so I'm hoping
that we'll see a schism in the American
Academy between those universities that
stand up and say this is madness we are
committed to providing a platform we
don't discriminate based on viewpoint in
politics that's the Chicago Way and
those that say no we're about social
justice come here we will train you to
fight for social justice and against the
right so if if people have clear choices
then I think we're gonna see a big
change and that's why I'm optimistic so
I think we're gonna see that